okay I saw I've just got a tweet here uh
this is from Penny Morden it looks like
uh penny mordant has dropped out of the
race
I am proud of the campaign we ran and
grateful to all of those across all
sides of our party who gave me their
backing we owe it to the country to each
other and to Rishi to unite and work
together for the good of the nation
there is much work to be done so there
you have it breaking news Penny mordant
just ahead of the announcement has
pulled out of the race you obviously did
not hit the numbers Rishi sunak is the
new prime minister Rishi sunak is the
new prime minister he won the majority
of the Parliamentary support after
losing the race so bitterly back in July
Penny mordant conceding let me read you
the whole statement our party is our
membership whether we are elected
representatives activists fundraisers or
supporters we all have a stake in who
our leader is these are unpredictable
times despite the compressed timetable
for the leadership contest it's clear
that colleagues feel we need certainty
today they have taken the decision in
good faith for the good of the country
members should know that this
proposition has been fairly and
thoroughly tested by the agreed 1922
process as a result we have chosen our
next prime minister this decision is a
historic one and shows once again the
diversity and talent of our party Rishi
sunak has our full support so there you
have it Rishi sanak is the next prime
minister and I've actually got James
cleverly the foreign secretary with me
James let me see if could I get this mic
off here is that possible no okay let's
just we'll talk into it James Penny
warden's conceded did she not have the
numbers or did she and she decided to
fold well I I don't know I don't know
but what was increasingly clear through
the last couple of days is that an
increasingly large number of
parliamentary colleagues were supporting
Rishi the thing that I've seen in my job
as foreign secretary is what country
needs I think what our friends
internationally need is for us to be
relentlessly focused on the job I think
that Rishi now is clearly has clear
mandated apology party to lead